because you guys did a great job of
keeping your wedding really small right
because I'm having the hardest time
doing this year yeah
that list is [ __ ] huge nation wedding
no it's because I've kept friends for so
[ __ ] long I had the same friend since
I was like [ __ ] 5 or 2 years old Wow
like we still keep in touch like you
etre raise it great ray and I have been
friends since I was 2 years old then
we're still good friends
I keep friends for a very [ __ ] long
time which is why we just want the type
of persons like if I [ __ ] with you I
[ __ ] with you for life if I hate you I
hate you for [ __ ] life I mean I stick
to my [ __ ] guns like I might dislike
somebody it's it's highly apparent which
isn't a lot of people yeah I mean it's
like a very small sect of people that I
might really really dislike but then
everybody else I generally like and if I
keep a friend for a long time I keep
them you know that's why I like when
during these whole the whole wedding
thing it's funny when I would get these
random messages especially after this
engagement video popped up right bunch
of messages like yo bro when's the
wedding and I would just write back
wasn't matter to you I have to say that
I'm saying it in a joking way kind of
for real - yeah you know because in my
mind I'm like The Audacity why the [ __ ]
would you come to my wedding dude the
[ __ ] are you did know people don't
realize because I don't realize this
until I was planning a wedding but you
pay for every person that shows up every
head has a price tag yeah it's like oh
[ __ ] you're a hundred bucks you're a
hundred bucks they're like what about my
plus one
[ __ ] your plus one dude I don't know
them and if you guys aren't married
they're for sure not coming so I guess
my girlfriend [ __ ] your girlfriend dude
how about that you guys just started
dating
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what I think it's
like like even my friend he just had to
he'd said I don't have a plus-one I'm
not like all come on man I'm like
whatever dude I told me oh you ain't go
she goes I'm gonna [ __ ] like cool go on
and I just go about the wedding cause it
costs money man dad the people have this
weird thing where I find it weird when
people don't know their position in
their friends life right like there's a
group of people if I didn't get invited
to the wedding I'd be like that's kind
of weird right but a majority of it it's
not right so there was another youtuber
I'll tell you laughter who had a wedding
and my friend was like oh so are you
going to his wedding and I'm like no he
didn't invite me they're like oh sure
like it's nothing happened I was like no
I don't think
that close yeah yeah it's like this cuz
we got drunk together a few times
doesn't mean that we're really close
friends yeah that's what would happen
it's like I would meet these people we
get drunk and I'm a very happy drunk
yeah I know David yeah I have the nicest
human being on [ __ ] earth right and
so next thing you know like people I got
invited to be this is a crazy [ __ ] right
actually did a video on this words this
dude asked me to be a part of his bridal
party or his groom groom party or
whatever groom party yes to be the ring
bearer
be a groomsman yeah and I was talking
him on the phone and force model you
know how I got my [ __ ] phone number
that's the weird part right and he goes
hey man like hey I would really
appreciate if you be a problem you know
I'm paraphrasing right now but and I was
just like Amen congrats bud nah dude you
know my god like I don't I'm not that
close to you Brian he goes what he said
to me which [ __ ] entertained me he
goes a man like to be honest was like
it's like it should be a pretty big
honor no that that's for Batum he's an
honor that he asked me to be a part of
his [ __ ] and I'm like who the [ __ ] you
know I was like rah I alerted him I said
bro I don't know you talked a couple
times and we're connected through this
other friend yeah but and then I called
him up you know the guy that connect I
was like yo did he are you a part of his
[ __ ] like are you one of his
groomsmen he goes yeah I was like are
you guys even close he goes not really
goes dude he asked me he goes bro he's
weird like he doesn't actually have a
lot of close friends so you know the few
times that you guys drink get that you
guys were buddy-buddy and I'm like [ __ ]
no guy you could if that guy died
tomorrow I literally would shed a tear
that's how little I know him like if he
died I would like well [ __ ] Jerry's
dead move on is they thought Jerry by
the way okay good did slip up earlier
yeah that's why we had the magic of
editing dude good
yeah well [ __ ] because that's why I'm
saying like people don't know their
position and or life and it's very odd
where they go because people use that
term that's my friend very easy right
like that's my friend I school oh no I
know yeah I mean but they yeah I don't
know what that shit's about I'm pretty
sure that probably happens to you a lot
especially because
where you came from and then people are
like oh that's you know that's TIF she's
my homegirl you know now they see like
you're in the limelight now yeah I was
about to ask you do you think he was
inviting you for the clout maybe but he
wouldn't want if he if I actually went
to that wedding that whole wedding I
would have embarrassed him I would have
grabbed the mic and I just roasted this
dude for in a full [ __ ] hour I got so
drunk once at a wedding where one of my
friends was giving the worst best man
speech I know booing any good to go yeah
i roasted i roasted the [ __ ] out of this
bull on the mic you know I mean like
that's the last thing that you want me
to do because I'll save that wedding
instant I was like took that [ __ ] away
man cuz I feel like for you that might
that might happen a lot yeah you know
it's funny I have cousins coming out of
the woodwork they're like hey you know
what you're friends with your Deana with
the cousin and the theme that goes in a
while that's like literally so many
times remove that we're not even like we
don't share the same blood but they're
still coming at me like hey and then my
mom's telling me she's like hey so this
this other pretty much of yours they
want your phone number and I'm like mom
you better not give my phone out to
these people I don't know them yeah I'll
give a [ __ ] if they're related but
they're not related I mean I didn't grow
up with these people we get it that's
the funniest one is where these all
these cousins from all these other
angles are coming out and saying hey my
thing is to when people come out and
they're like yo man I'm I'm so [ __ ]
proud of you
I'm like proud of me for what bro who
the [ __ ] are you did you know me like
that [ __ ] are you saying right now man
they're proud of you David are you proud
of me
okay go good job proud of you - you
[ __ ] loser hell man like it's because
they want something and it always come
down yeah always comes out later on
right it's like god this I know I just
wanted to congratulate we talked about
you being stuck up and then later on
it's like yo man like I'm going through
some hard to get get some money it's
like oh so there it is you want some
money lo and behold I'm broke [ __ ] you
[ __ ] know did beat you huh would you
think these businesses just popped up
out of nowhere that's where all my money
is [ __ ]
[ __ ] poor okay and like stephanie was
talking about this to where she said
like people from back in they just
I'm loving the answer from money you
know she's like well I do often I should
give us I know you don't give those
people money because in my mind is like
if I have a surplus of money I'm gonna
give to the people that really do matter
that do count that have supported me and
I'll give it to them they may have to
pay me back I'll just [ __ ] give to
them
yeah and it's weird and that's where
that survivor survivor's guilt comes
from it's like oh [ __ ] maybe I should
give it away because I don't deserve
this money exactly you know that does
happen but luckily I haven't been
situations like that girls I don't know
I couldn't see myself like Stefan giving
money baby
do not give money away good thing
Stephanie she said in the podcast that
she doesn't but she has that guilt
unless her husband is really smart
so he's like nah you're not doing that
that was [ __ ] that's dead yeah I mean
cuz I I just don't like I just hate that
[ __ ] I hate it when people say they're
proud of you because they want something
out you because it kind of takes away
from from the hard work that you've kind
of put in right yeah because I think
that when when we kind of look at it on
a surface area it's like okay well
people because a lot of people say that
they could do what we do it's like cool
because I would never say that about
somebody else's career yeah right that's
so interesting cuz like the whole JK
Party thing happening
everyone's like dude I could easily take
over your drawer like why are you even
there like you're so blah blah blah and
I'm just like oh please please come play
a game with us I would love that
no even people - they're like oh can I
be a guest on your podcast I don't know
who they are but they hit me about the
email no you can't because you would be
the most uninteresting human being on
earth
I already know off the bat you have
nothing to say like you literally had
nothing to say like people think that
they have something to say but they
don't they actually don't because not a
lot of people can elaborate on their
thoughts yeah you may have been through
a lot of things but if I bring you on
this place and it's my job to bring that
out of you and the whole time I'm just
exhausted trying to talk to you yeah
it's not going to [ __ ] happen